throughout the country ninety percent of
city states are going to go bankrupt
within the next five years and probably
many of them sooner hi I'm Tim Cavanaugh
reason TV we're here with former Los
Angeles Mayor Richard Riordan your honor
thanks for joining us oh thanks for
having me mayor Antonio Villaraigosa
just recently broke from pattern
certainly at he's a longtime Union
supporter and teachers union member yet
he has recently been thumping the tub
saying that the teachers are in a way of
reform and what does that mean well you
know it's curious because I've been out
there thin the articles I've had in the
Wall Street Journal New York Times and
others very critical of me Revere Ragosa
particularly on the pensions in the
future and a lot of other issues like
closing the libraries and weekends and
at nights and then he comes up with this
incredibly great talk blaming the unions
for their poor education system I said
hallelujah I'm going to forget
everything I didn't like about him and I
think he's the greatest mayor that ever
lived now the unions do not want any
accountability they put in competent
adults ahead of children educating
children so they have the tools to
compete in a high-tech society in the
future is the best thing not only for
the children but for the country because
we can't compete with other countries we
don't have the young people who can do
the high-tech jobs that the end in India
they can do China they can do Malaysia
they can do the Democrats have shown
some some pretty broad disenchantment
with teachers unions and public sector
unions in particular of late and you
know that government goes starting with
Governor Brown what does this mean when
you have this broad consensus among the
Republicans and the Democrats and the
the people that the these organizations
are really taking up too much of our
money standing the way of reform and yet
nothing changes I would call it a broad
consensus yet because clearly if you
take like Sacramento the legislature
there is still overwhelmingly controlled
by the unions but there's a better you
know break in the ice before it like
you're
Ragosa coming in Obama through Arne
Duncan the race to the top has come in
people think that Governor Brown may
come in he at charter school that he
supported in Oakland but the legislators
are all there they're elected because
the unions they're afraid to vote
against the unions but I'm hoping that
what V Ragosa did could be the atomic
bomb that will wake everybody up
particularly poor people and say my
child has a right to go to college my
rough childhoods right to upward
mobility to be anything they want I
don't want this kind of education I'm
sorry your honor it's a little late in
the day to be saying there's any
greatness in Antonio but because we live
in hope a lot of folks on the Left will
say that the problem with LA with
California with the United States is
that the rich are not paying their fair
share in taxes is that it is the problem
that we could we solve our financial
problems by taxing the rich more the
answer is absolutely not and I'm a rich
guy so I can you know I live extremely
well I do give well over half of my
wealth to charities and particularly for
anything dealing with poor children and
a lot of rich people do that and unless
we educate kids to be able to be
executives top employees and everything
in high technology those kids are going
to have nowhere to go 10 years from now
they'll be poor they'll be out a job and
they'll probably be revolting unless we
figure out some way to solve the problem
you cannot solve the problem by saying
okay we're going to redistribute because
raising taxes is a way of redistributing
redistributing the wealth every place in
the world has every tried that has been
a dismal failure you look at England in
the 50s they had a brain drain where the
wealthy moved including the Beatles
moved out of the country and by the end
of the 50s England was bankrupt Margaret
Thatcher saved them in that time and you
saw Chile under Elyan d I mean God
within a year he like doubled the income
of the poor and within a year the whole
country was bankrupt in the case of LA
what would be a smarter tax policy what
could we do in the way we collect taxes
in LA to to make the city more
competitive I think you asked the wrong
question is how do you make the city
more competitive as a right question and
you do it by having a city with
bureaucrats and the City Council the
mayor being friendly to business you
talked at small businesses or any
business it takes them forever to get
permits to start a business in LA the
fees and everything have gone up
dramatically who wants to start a
business in Los Angeles forget the
amount of taxes and this is when they're
not banning your business outright as
you see in all of these things and
especially in the 8th district where the
ban on fast food the ban on the cool
yeah and and big-box stores which are
the ones that bring taxes in the big box
stores of sales taxes yeah and you know
again it's a unions don't want them
because the big box stores compete with
the unionized grocery stores and other
things being a wealthy guy I don't mind
paying more taxes if they're going to do
the right thing but I don't know if you
ever heard of a see Northcote Parkinson
yes yeah he had a magic thing if the
total taxes go over twenty-five percent
a lot of bad things happen the rich can
right now in this internet age rich can
run their company from any place in the
world they don't have to be in
California they don't have to be in the
united states california and
particularly LA are unfriendly to
business and we haven't created an
infrastructure haven't done virtually
nothing for an infrastructure in the
last 30 years and a lot of companies
have left they've expanded how many
apple and intel other companies have
expanded outside of the united states or
at least outside of California you have
any hope for California as a sort of
test case
says this kind of Keynesian
interventionist laboratory where we have
everything Democrats are in control the
Republicans have been extinguished the
threshold for raising taxes has been
lowered the every really every aspect of
human behavior has some regulation over
it there are a million environmental
regulations there's a high-speed rail
effort so how's that all going to end up
total collapse unless something is done
what's going to happen not just to
California can have more in California
others but throughout the country ninety
percent of cities states are going to go
bankrupt within the next five years and
probably many of them sooner and they
want the the big thing they won't be
able to sell raise money by selling
bonds nobody wants to lend the money and
so the federal government if Obama wants
to get reelected he's going to face some
part of this because some of them
happened before 2012 and you'll have
total disarray the parks will be closed
the libraries will be closed them cut
down twenty five percent or more on the
number of police it'll be a total
collapse the Obama administration has
not focused on this what's your
assessment of Governor Schwarzenegger he
got up into Sacramento where he had all
these great ideas and you had a
legislature that was controlled by the
unions so if you wanted to do things on
education the Union stopped you and and
then he had to make some peace with the
unions and then the Republicans would
stop him at ya ah you know I I shouldn't
say I feel sorry for him but because I
don't think he feels sorry for himself
the la's political class and it's all
and it's almost entirely Democratic at
this point is really I mean it's a south
of the mason-dixon line level of
politics in a way that I think would
shock Americans in other places is there
any hope for for you know just la's
political class and maybe specifically
for the Republicans well you know you
would think so that because usually
you know Republicans go towards the
middle the Democrats go through the
middle and you get a pretty balanced
type legislature but it hasn't happened
it's gotten worse as you point out and
where it's going to be I don't know but
if there's disaster in the city is the
politicians going to change or the
public going to realize we have to elect
different people I hope it's the latter
you